So we've seen how me can mean me, to me or myself, and te can mean you, to you or yourself
And nos can mean us, to us, or ourselves.
So we want to resist the temptation to translate this to.
So for example, he speaks to me
We don't need this to because me, me, can mean me, to me or myself.
So we want to resist the temptation to translate that to
So how do you say he speaks to me or he's speaking to me?
And don't let that sorry, meh appla.
Yeah, don't let that too confuse you about the position
It should go.
It's still going before.
Meabla.
They speak to me.
Meablan.
Good.
If you want to say they speak to me about it, you can just say they speak me it in Spanish.
Me lo hablan.
Very good.
They're speaking to me about it.
So this too and this about, we notice Spanish tends not to need these words as much as English does.
For example, to buy was comprar.
Komprar.
Good.
So this me, other than to me
Can be for me, from me.
We don't really need these words.
So for example, if we want to say he buys it for me, we can just say he buys me it.
So comparar is to buy.
He buys it for me.
He buys me it.
Make law
Compra.
Good.
Me lo compra.
So here we see me is like for me here.
But it's just me.
We're just using me.
I buy it for you, speaking informally.
I buy it for you.
Te lo compro.
Good.
Now, if you want to say shall I buy it for you?
Shall in English, all it's doing really is just making it a question.
Shall I buy it for you?
So in Spanish, just make it sound like a question.
Te lo compro?
Yeah.
Shall I buy it for you?
Now this could actually even mean from you.
Shall I buy it from you?
So by the context we'll understand the difference.
Maybe you will hear if you travel to a Spanish-speaking country, people say, buy me selling things in the street
Buy me something is what you will hear.
And they're probably not asking you to buy them something, but to buy something from them.
And it's understood and we don't really need to use these words like from or for most of the time.
To do was aser.
Aser.
How would you say do you want to do?
Speaking informally.
Acer is a irregular verb.
Doesn't matter, does it?
Do you want to do?
Ah.
Quiere hacer.
Good.
Do you want to do it?
Now how do you think you will say, do you want to do it for me?
Me lo quieres hacer.
Yes.
So we're not using the word fufo.
We don't need it in Spanish.
It's understood.
Do you want to do it for me?
Me lo quieres hacer.
Quieres hacer me lo?
Good.
The kitchen in Spanish is La Cocina, La Cocina, or in most of Spain La Cocina, Cocina, La Cocina, La Cocina.
And to cook.
is cosinar.
You just make a verb from cosina.
Cosinar.
Actually this is where we get concoction, concoction from in English with cooking.
So how would you say I cook from Cocinar?
Cosino.
Good.
How do you say he cooks or she cooks or it cooks or usted you formal cook?
Cocina.
Good.
You informal?
Cocinas.
Good.
And with emphasis or clarification, if you want to use the word for you.
Usted?
But this is informal cosinas.
Ah sorry.
Tu cosinas.
Two cosinas.
Good.
They cook or you guys
What if we wanted to use the word for they to emphasize or to clarify?
Eyos kosinan.
Good.
Oh elas.
if it's a female group.
What if we wanted to say you guys are cooking with the emphasis on the clarification
Ustedes cocinan.
Good.
And we cook, what is we cook?
And with the emphasis or the clarification?
Nosotros cocinamos.
Good.
How would you say I can?
How is I can related to power?
Puedo.
Good.
And he can?
Puede.
Good.
And you can inform her?
Puedes.
Good.
Can you cook?
Can you cook something for me?
So what was the word for something?
Algo.
Good.
How do you think you're gonna say this in Spanish?
Can you cook something for me?
Cocinar algo?
Good.
Me puedes cocinar algo.
Puedes cocinarme algo, either way.
So how would you say I have cooked?
I have cooked.
E cocinado.
E cocinado, good.
So we said that this this tense of have cooked.
I have cooked instead of I cooked.
We can use it more in Spanish than in English.
So for example, in English it sounds much more natural to say I cooked at six o'clock.
But in Spanish it's not a problem to say I have cooked at six o'clock.
So, at six o'clock is Allah says.
What do actually mean when you say Allah says is Allah says horas
At the six hours.
A little bit like in English when you say at 1600 hours.
Alas says.
So how would you say I have cooked at six o'clock?
I cooked at six o'clock.
E cocinado a las seis.
Good.
I have cooked at six o'clock.
I cooked at six o'clock.
Good.
The word for eight in Spanish is ocho.
Ocho.
We have this similar root in octagon, you know, a shape with eight sides.
or octopus, which has eight legs, or in October, which, although now it's the tenth month, in the Roman calendar there were only ten months, and October was month number eight
So 8 or 8.
How would you say we have cooked at 8 o'clock?
We have cooked at 8 o'clock
Hemos cocinado a las ocho.
Good.
The word for nine in Spanish is 9.
We can see in November, which used to be the ninth month, they're all splits into UE
9.
And we have the same with ten.
Ten is dies or dief in most of Spain.
What does that sound like?
If we go back to our calendar.
December.
December, which used to be the tenth month.
And of course again an example of splitting test to dies.
Quedar in Spanish, quedar means to remain or to be left over.
And it actually has quite a few other meanings as well.
It's quite a
flexible verb quedar.
But for now, to remain or to be left over.
Q U E D A R Quedar.
And QU in Spanish is always a K sound.
You must resist any temptation to pronounce kwe dar if you were to read this.
The word ke, the word for what that we learnt is spelled Q-U-E.
Quiero is spelled Q U I E R O.
So Q U, this combination is always a K.
Quedar means to remain
So in Spanish if you want to say I stay, actually you say I remain myself.
This is the way you say I stay in Spanish.
So we start with remain, which is quedar.
So how do you say I remain?
Kedo.
The E doesn't split here, but good for trying.
I remain myself.
Me quedo.
This means I stay.
Until until in Spanish is hasta, hasta.
H A S T A.
You may have heard hasta la vista until the view.
Literally until the seeing until we see each other.
Hasta la vista.
So now you can say I'm staying here until 10 o'clock.
So let's divide it up.
I'm staying here, I remain myself here
Until Ast.
So it's literally like last
10 horas, but you don't say horas.
Maybe historically people said it, but not anymore.
Me kedo aquí or acá hasta las 10.
Good.
I'm staying until ten o'clock.
So if Mekedo, I remain myself, is I'm staying, how do you think you would say we are staying?
good but now you have some draw harmony popping in because we were concentrating on on the other bit so this mistake managed to come back
Quedamos.
Good, because it's quedar, no?
Nos quedamos.
We remain ourselves, we stay.
So we're staying until nine o'clock.
Good.
Nos quedamos hasta las nueve.
Very good.
You stay or you remain yourself speaking informally?
Te quedas.
Good.
You're staying here?
Te quedas aquí.
Are you staying here?
Te quedas aquí?
Good.
Te quedas aquí.
How would you make it emphatic now?
Are you staying here?
Because this te is not emphatic.
It's not optional.
where you have to put this me in me kedo to get the meaning of stay.
And we have to put this te in te quedas to get the meaning of stay.
But if we want to make it emphatic, what do we add?
Tu te chiedas?
Good.
I'm staying emphatic.
Yo me quedo.
Good.
We're staying.
Nos quedamos.
Good.
We are staying.
Nosotros nos quedamos.
Very good.